i think i speak for so many people
right now which is we've been through
hell the last two days and i am finding
that the more
i watch television almost the less i
know
we've hit an inflection point if i see
john
king with that stupid map one more time
tell me about a district that hasn't
come in yet
in some part of the country i've never
heard of where there's six votes
maybe i'm gonna start hitting people
just randomly hitting people
so tell me first of all we are taping
this
it is uh 11 30 a.m
and it is thursday and so
things may have changed dramatically by
the time
people watch this tonight uh do you
think it's possible that we
could have um a
i'm not going to call them the winner
but the major networks call
a a uh uh a winner in this
presidential contest today could that
happen
it could happen today i'll tell you the
network so
it's a very weird cycle and i'll just
say
compared to four years ago this week i'd
take this scenario as exhausting
and as tedious as it is over what
happened four years ago
because i'll tell you the view from both
the biden
orbit and the trump orbit is that joe
biden is most likely the next president
of the united states
so a trump source told me yesterday that
these lawsuits because
other than the map that's the other
thing we're talking about on tv
that these lawsuits are mostly designed
and ordered up by the client who's
donald trump and if you remember when
his fixer michael cohen testified
you know who had the job of bringing a
lot of lawsuits for
donald trump when he was a private
citizen they're usually without cause
without merit they're
they're punitive they're to settle
scores or to settle grudges
in donald trump's mind i think they are
to
save him or spare him from the
humiliation of rejection
which you know folks that have followed
his personal life
know that that is the thing he fears
more than anything i don't think he's
afraid of not being in charge of the
country i think he's afraid of being
rejected
he is petrified petrified of losing
nobody
likes to lose um i can speak personally
you do get used to it
grow accustomed to it in time it becomes
a part of life
uh but uh he fears it
greatly and i think what he really wants
to do in my opinion
is throw up a lot of dust and i think
what
what the trump strategy now is most
likely
i do not get a second term but what i
want
all of my followers to think is that we
were robbed
and it's almost it's a bloody shirt that
he and his people and his family can
wave
uh for the next 20 years
with whatever they're doing and that's
what it feels like this is all set up
for
that's what it is but that's how he
governed as president when he won when
he won
it was all about getting robbed when he
won four years ago
instead of being honored and humbled and
um reading for the first time and
listening for the first time
he spent four years talking about being
robbed and
investigated and attacked he never slid
into the role
this will be a much more comfortable
adjustment to actually be rejected
and to actually make up a cover story
for it
than it was for him to have won four
years ago
i mean he never made that leap so
i think that the the flip side of this
which people
in in my line of work are doing a real i
think injustice and not spending as much
attention talking about is that yes
donald trump
has most likely been rejected joe biden
has most likely
won after losing the first three
democratic primary contests
spectacularly
after being left for dead politically by
the democratic elite by the media
he went on to have this incredible
victory in the south carolina primary
he then had really you talk about
landslides and waves he had a landslide
wave victory
in super tuesday and then to beat a
republican
in this age of fox news we talk about
fox because they're sort of the tallest
uh building in that universe but there's
a whole
um fake news ecosystem that
we will look back in a few years and
find it remarkable that
anybody could get through and
win in this kind of political climate
you